In October of 1347, devastation and disease
came to the shores of Europe.
Twelve ships from the Black Sea docked at
the port of Messina in Sicily, and as citizens
waited on the docks to welcome the sailors
home, they were horrified to discover that
almost everyone aboard the ships had been
lost.
They were still there, but they had succumbed
to a mysterious illness, their bodies covered
in terrible black boils.
Everyone was warned to get away, to let the
authorities clear these ships of death out
of the harbor, but it was already too late.
The Black Death had arrived.
The people of Europe had heard rumors, whispers
of a Great Pestilence working its way through
the trade routes of the East, leaving desolation
in its wake as it raged through China, India,
Persia, and Syria.
There were stories of swollen boils under
the armpits, of fever, chills, aches and pains,
and, before long...death.
The illness worked so swiftly a man could
go to bed the picture of perfect health and
be dead by morning.
Now, this same pestilence had landed in the
harbor and come up onto land, and the invisible
hand of death and sickness had a grip on everyone's
throats.
Shortly after the plague's arrival in Italy,
it spread to the port of Marseilles in France,
then continued on to Rome, Florence, Paris,
Bordeaux, Lyon, and London.
As the pestilence continued its uncontrollable
spread, people everywhere were terrified.
Something was invading their homes and taking
their loved ones, and they had no idea what
was causing it, or how to treat it.
Some doctors believed that the disease was
caused by miasma, foul-smelling air that carried
the plague on its breeze.
Others believed it to be a spiritual sickness,
spread when the airborne spirit of a sick
man floated out of his eyes and attacked a
healthy person unfortunate enough to make
eye contact with him.
Others thought it must be divine punishment,
God's answer to the relentless sins of mankind.
Amidst the chaos and mistrust, the finger-pointing
and desperate attempts to find something,
anything to blame, doctors did their best
to treat patients with the limited information
they had.
Proposed cures ranged from the useless and
ridiculous to the downright dangerous.
Some physicians prescribed bloodletting, pricking
open veins to let the disease flow out of
a patient's body, along with most of the blood
they needed to stay alive.
Others had the sick take baths in vinegar
and rosewater, which wouldn't harm them, but
did little to stop the progress of the disease.
Some cures were expensive, calling for an
emerald to be ground into powder and mixed
into a glass of wine.
Other treatments were honestly a fate worse
than simple death, and included drinking one's
own urine, ingesting snakeskin and precious
metals, and drinking the pus from lanced boils.
Working with plague patients was a potentially
deadly undertaking, and the few doctors brave
enough to take on the task needed to take
as many precautions as possible.
They were outfitted with a specialized uniform:
an ankle-length overcoat, gloves, boots, and
a bird-like mask ending in a pointed beak.
The mask contained a rudimentary respirator-like
device filled with dried flowers and herbs,
spices, camphor, or a vinegar sponge.
They believed that, by overpowering any potential
bad smells, the scented mask would protect
against the diseased air.
The costume included a wide-brimmed leather
hat, and a wooden cane used to examine patients
without touching them.
All in all, a plague doctor's attire was easily
recognizable, and more than a little ominous
in appearance.
However, what might be unsettling to see today,
or even a signifier of an especially dangerous
and misguided humanoid anomaly contained by
the SCP Foundation, was once a symbol of hope
in a dark time.
Seeing a man enter town in a long dark coat,
a leather hat, and a birdlike mask meant that,
perhaps, all was not yet lost.
And so, as news traveled about a mysterious
illness stealing souls in the night, turning
their bodies into masses of infectious boils
that needed to be rounded up and burned in
pits outside of town, the people of a tiny
French village were anxiously awaiting the
arrival of one such Plague Doctor.
They hoped a physician would arrive before
the first person fell ill, but they could
feel the cloud of illness creeping ever closer.
It was a joyful day when, one morning, a young
man ran through the town square, banging a
pot and a pan together and crying out: "A
doctor is here!
A doctor has come to town!"
Indeed, just behind the young man came a stranger,
dressed in long black robes and wearing a
wide-brimmed hat.
However, instead of the beaked mask, this
man's face was covered in a rather curious
manner.
He wore a white porcelain mask, frozen in
a permanent smile.
Behind the eyes and open mouth, the villagers
could see only darkness.
This must, they thought, be some sort of new
preventative measure, some protective gear
he had brought with him from whatever medically
advanced city he had just been in.
Still, before getting their hopes up, the
people wanted to be sure.
"Excuse me."
An older farmer, a respected pillar of the
community, approached the masked man.
"Are you a physician?"
"Indeed, I am!"
The stranger replied cheerfully.
"I have reason to believe the Black Death
will shortly come to this little town, and
I was sent here to provide my services to
anyone who may need them."
In case there was any question about his identity,
he produced from his side a large doctor's
bag, filled with tinctures and tools, with
rags soaked in vinegar and vials of ground-up
eggshells and saffron.
The townspeople couldn't help but feel lucky
that such a well-equipped physician had come
to their town, to arm them with the tools
they needed to combat the plague.
Later that day, their fortunes seemed to double
when yet another stranger strode into town.
This man was dressed far more traditionally,
in the garb the people had come to expect
from a physician tasked with treating the
Black Death.
The man was dressed in long dark robes, leather
gloves, boots, and a beaked mask.
He carried a bag, similar to that of the first
doctor.
The same older farmer approached the doctor,
curious to see two newcomers on the same day.
He couldn't remember the last time he saw
so many strangers arriving in their little
hamlet at the same time.
"Have you come to help us, Doctor?"
He asked.
"Fear not, my good fellow.
I have.
I am here to fight the Great Pestilence, and
I will lend you all of my effort and years
of medical knowledge.
Tell me, are there any infected yet?
I would be happy to treat them."
The farmer shook his head.
"We are all healthy here, Sir.
But it is fortuitous indeed, to have two great
physicians here to aid us in these troubling
times."
The Doctor tilted his head to the side, perplexed.
"Two?
I assure you, I am traveling quite alone."
"The man who arrived before you!"
The farmer insisted.
"Come and meet him, I'm sure you two will
have a lot to talk about."
More than a little confused, the Plague Doctor
followed the farmer to the town's tavern,
where he was ushered to a table that had one
occupant: the man in the white mask.
He greeted the Doctor with that frozen porcelain
smile, and a tone that was filled with mannered
congeniality.
"Ah, another Doctor!
Welcome, my dear colleague.
It will be a pleasure to work with you."
The Plague Doctor sat across from the Mask,
and stared at him inquisitively.
"I was unaware there would be another physician
in town, please forgive my confusion."
"Not to worry!"
The Mask's smile seemed to widen, though of
course that was impossible.
"It will be a relief to have someone else
to share the burden.
I am certain we will work together quite well."
"Tell me," The Plague Doctor began, "How did
you come to hear of the need for a doctor
in this town?
It is my understanding that none have fallen
ill thus far."
"Rumors, that is all.
And in times such as these, one can never
be too careful.
After all, we took an oath to help those in
need, did we not?"
The Plague Doctor couldn't place why, but
he felt strangely apprehensive about this
fellow in the white mask.
Something about him did not seem quite right,
from his untraditional choice of attire, to
the rustling sound inside of the man's bag,
to the strange droplets of something black
that had gathered on the table in front of
him.
Still, perhaps the exhaustion of his journey
had put him on edge.
Many hands make for lighter work, and he should
be grateful for the assistance promised.
He was used to working alone, but he would
simply have to adjust.
Besides, it was entirely possible no one would
become ill at all, and the letter he had received
summoning him to the town was based on inaccurate
assessments of the area's risk.
He would stay a fortnight, evaluate the health
of the people, and, if nothing of import arose,
he would travel onward to the next town and
continue his endless battle against the Pestilence.
But before that fortnight could pass, someone
did fall ill.
The old farmer's wife ran to the tavern in
the early hours of the morning, only two days
after the Doctors came to town.
The Plague Doctor was already awake when she
arrived, sipping a cup of tea and eating a
piece of toasted bread with butter.
She begged him to leave his breakfast and
come inspect her husband immediately.
Her husband had collapsed while milking the
cows, and nothing she did could wake him.
His forehead felt hot to the touch, slick
with sweat.
As he looked, the Plague Doctor could see
that the farmer's body was covered in the
tell-tale boils that he had seen so many times
before.
He instructed the woman to stand back, to
stay away from her husband lest she catch
his sickness.
Then, he began a thorough inspection, using
his cane to lift the man's arms and check
beneath them.
Sure enough, there were more boils there.
"Your husband is very ill."
He told the weeping woman.
"But I assure you, Madame, I will do my best
to make him well.
We will begin by letting the blood from these
areas."
He pulled a scalpel from his bag, and began
the procedure.
"This will release the humors that have gathered
in excess, and allow his body to regain balance."
"It will not work."
A voice behind him disturbed his careful work,
and the Plague Doctor turned around, to see
the white-masked man watching him from the
doorway.
"I beg your pardon?"
The Plague Doctor straightened.
"This man needs a different cure.
Please, allow me to treat him."
The Plague Doctor hesitated, uncertain about
having his methods questioned.
But the pleading cries of the farmer's wife
persuaded him to step back and allow his colleague
to try his own treatment.
"Very well, I will let you work."
The Plague Doctor left the room to give the
white-masked man some privacy.
The farmer's wife joined him, and the two
sat in the front room of the house, waiting
for whatever news the other doctor might bring.
Finally, after many hours, he returned.
"I am very sorry."
The man's white mask now bore the expression
of a deep, sorrowful frown.
His gloved hands were covered with blood.
"Your husband's condition was far too advanced.
If I had arrived sooner to treat him, and
if his blood had not been let so hastily by
my colleague, perhaps I would have saved him.
But he is with the angels now."
The woman began to cry again, and as she wiped
her eyes, the Plague Doctor noticed the masked
man do the same, wiping something thick and
black from the eye holes of his mask.
Strange.
And then there were the words he had said,
words that offended the Doctor to his very
core.
"Are you implying I am to be held responsible
for this lost patient?"
He demanded.
"Of course not, it was the Plague that took
his life.
But...well, we will never know exactly what
might have happened if I had arrived to treat
him first.
Never mind, best not to dwell on such hypothetical
matters."
The white-masked man held out a cup to the
grieving widow, filled with something dark
and viscous.
"My dear lady, in caring for your husband
you were exposed to his sickness.
You will take ill and follow him into death
if you do not take care to prevent the plague
from taking in you.
Please, drink this.
It will keep you safe."
Before the Plague Doctor could ask what the
unfamiliar medicine was, the woman had already
taken the cup with trembling hands, and drank
its contents in one swallow.
"Please do call on me if anything else troubles
you.
My condolences for your loss."
And with that, the white-masked man was gone.
The farmer was the first citizen to succumb
to the Black Plague, but sadly, he would not
be the last.
Once the disease had its hooks in the town,
it was going to be difficult to root it out.
In spite of taking the strange curative drink,
the farmer's wife was lost only a few days
later.
All throughout the town, more and more grew
ill, and it seemed there was no relief in
sight.
The Plague Doctor did his best to treat the
patients as they came, providing them with
homemade tinctures of herbs and wild mushrooms,
cleaning their wounds with distilled spirits,
bathing them in the purest of vinegar.
He even resorted to some of his more experimental
treatments, those his colleagues in Paris
had questioned, had dismissed as far too close
to the occult and far too removed from science.
He took the blood from a healthy cow and attempted
to transmit it into a human patient.
He deliberately stopped the heart and then
started it again with the venom of an exotic
snake.
Still, he was unable to save any of them.
He was beginning to lose faith in himself,
and the people of the village were following
suit.
Slowly, the families of the sick were beginning
to bring their loved ones to the man in the
white mask instead, trusting only him to help
them.
And, somehow, help them he did.
The Plague Doctor couldn't be sure what the
white-masked man was doing.
His supposed colleague was secretive about
his methods, never allowing himself to be
observed.
He would not leave his makeshift workshop,
a room in the attic of the tavern where he
saw his patients.
But, whatever he was doing must have worked,
because for every one of his losses, there
was a person whose fever broke, whose skin
miraculously cleared of blemishes, and who
returned home to their life just as it was
before.
The Plague Doctor couldn't understand it,
any of it.
He had cured patients before, he knew he had.
His successes had been renowned throughout
the land, had earned him commendations from
generals and kings.
But now, here, ever since he met this new
doctor in the eerie white mask, something
was terribly wrong with his work.
Perhaps the other doctor would allow him to
assist, to learn from him.
In his current sorry state, Plague Doctor
could only hope to become the assistant of
a great man.
Once he had absorbed some of his knowledge,
perhaps then he could return to his former
state, do as much good as he once had.
One evening after he finished his supper of
vegetable soup and crusty bread, the Plague
Doctor summoned his courage and decided to
go upstairs and pay the masked man a visit.
As he lifted his fist to knock on the door,
he could hear muffled voices coming from the
other side.
He was not ordinarily one to eavesdrop, but
something in the tone of the conversation
made him hesitate and listen for a moment.
"I am afraid you might be right."
The Mask said.
"There is something unusual about the other
Doctor.
I do not wish to cast aspersions, but...it
seems as if the Plague only began to appear
here once he arrived in town."
"Do you think...he brought the disease with
him?"
The other voice, belonging to the local judge,
replied.
"I am sorry to say that I do."
"What can be done to stop this?
To drive the Plague out of our community?"
The judge asked.
"In my opinion, there is only one choice.
The Doctor must leave this town.
By choice or by force, dead or alive...that
will be up to him."
The Plague Doctor clapped a hand over his
beak in shock.
Conspiracy against him?
But why?!
He could hear rustling on the other side of
the door, someone preparing to open it.
He must hide before they spotted him!
He ducked into a closet, shutting the door
behind him, and tucked himself away in the
dark as the judge's footsteps passed by outside.
Finally, it fell silent.
With a sigh of relief, the Plague Doctor pushed
open the closet door.
But there, waiting for him, was that unmoving
pale white face.
This time, it was smiling, a malicious, gleeful
smile.
"Oh, hello, Doctor."
The Masked Man said.
His words were polite, but his voice was cruel
and cold.
"What have you done?
Why would you tell the people such slanderous
lies?"
The Plague Doctor demanded.
"Simple.
They need someone to blame, and I won't have
it be me."
The Masked man laughed then, a hollow sound.
"Haven't you figured it out, Doctor?
Haven't your brilliant deductive skills led
you to the answer?
Why your cures have done nothing, why all
of your patients perish while so many of mine
thrive?"
"...You made them ill?
Deliberately?
But how?
And why?"
The Plague Doctor gaped in shock and horror.
"The how is for me to know and take to the
grave.
But as for the why...
I'd be happy to tell you, because no one will
believe a word you say.
I intend to rule this town, the first of many
I will make my domain.
And there is no way to inspire loyalty in
a population like freeing them from the grip
of the Black Death.
Unfortunate that you had to arrive and complicate
my plans.
But you will soon be taken care of, and then
I will have nothing more to worry about."
The Mask cackled again, triumphant and wicked.
"You VILLAIN!"
The Plague Doctor roared, grabbing at the
man's robes and trying to yank him close enough
to fight.
He could not get a grip on the man, but the
robes came loose and fell to the ground, revealing
a horrible sight.
Where there should have been a man, flesh
and blood and beating heart, there was nothing
but a skeleton, dripping black slime onto
the floor.
The mask covered a face of bone and desiccated
skin, the body underneath a rattling marionette
propelled by unnatural, evil forces.
It was too much for the Plague Doctor to take,
and he did the only thing he could think to
do: he turned, and he ran.
The Plague Doctor grabbed his cane, his trusty
apothecary bag, and ran out into the streets.
"Please!"
He cried out into the night.
"Listen to me!
You have been fooled by a Devil!
He brings desolation, not the cure!
He is the sickness!"
"You're a madman!"
The judge cried, brandishing a flaming torch
in one hand, a pitchfork in the other.
"You brought death to our town, and now you
spout lies about our savior!"
"Please, my dear fellow, hear me!
You are not safe here!"
The Plague Doctor begged.
The judge lunged at him with the pitchfork,
and, forgetting to touch the man with his
cane, the Plague Doctor grabbed his arm with
his own hand to stop the assault.
The judge's eyes went wide, and he dropped
to the ground in a lifeless heap.
"He killed him!"
Cried a bystander.
"The false doctor is a murderer!"
As the Plague Doctor watched, an angry mob
descended on him, waving their torches and
weapons.
They would not hear reason, they would not
listen.
He would have to flee.
The Plague Doctor ran until the cries of angry
townspeople and the glow of their torches
had faded into dark and silence.
And then he ran some more.
He ran all the way to a neighboring town,
where he told stories of a shambling corpse
in a white porcelain mask, bringing a Plague
of illness and deception, and could only hope
and pray that these people would listen.
Now go check out “When Day Breaks SCP-049”
and “SCP-001 - Can SCP-049 Finally Cure
When Day Breaks?”
for more battles of wits between the Plague
Doctor and the diabolical possessive mask!